let's talk about the family guard and
their guest Play Day initiative talk a
little bit about what it is and then
also why it was important for you to get
involved the yes play initiative
um really rang with me because it's
encouraging families to spend time
together to say yes to play to say yes
to just this quality bonding time
usually nine times that it's in that
we're never gonna get back with our kids
you know so having this time to bond to
hang out with them to in a clean safe
space is always a blessing of course but
the initiative in dividing fifty
thousand dollars amongst a hundred
families just to have the resources to
have this safe clean space to play and
for development to take place for Wonder
to take place is really dope you know
you think about how simple that is but
how also effective it is for our kids so
that's what really really um caught my
eye caught my attention because I'm all
about playtime with my kids and it's the
most I mean no pun intended but it's the
most fun I do have with my kids is when
we're playing or that nighttime sweet
spot when we're reading books together
so this is right up my alley for sure
and like you said it's you know
prioritizing playing together as a
family what is what are the activities
that your family enjoys doing together
the most oh my goodness cooking
um we love watching movies together on
Sundays that's what we do like we watch
cartoons
um together what's the go-to cartoon
right now go to Cartoon right now for
some strange reason is Tom and Jerry
like they are obsessed with Tom and
Jerry uh I know I love the classic too I
love that they love the classics um they
also love the Magic School Bus
I mean honest your kids have excellent
taste I mean I'm trying to train them up
the right way I feel like we have the
good stuff for that time
um and what else do we do yeah we cook
together we watch movies together uh we
go to museums together at home I can be
stuck with Magna tiles which is why
these are behind me because the brand
knows of course said that's what I like
but we can do Magna tiles for hours
and it's so much fun Legos for hours
Magna tiles for hours I mean I think
I've kind of like made myself dizzy from
you know making the trucks go and having
you know little contests and stuff like
that but we have a good time together no
matter what we do
um you know I love
um the way that you speak about your uh
boys what do you think you've learned
the most about yourself since becoming a
mom is there anything that surprised you
the most or anything that you've sort of
just you've learned about yourself
um
I'd say
[Music]
wow what would I what have I learned
about myself
that I have more patience than I thought
it was the one thing that actually
scared me about being a mom because I
didn't have a lot of patience and I
remember that
making me really fearful because I know
that with parenting you have to be super
patient and you're really on their time
that you're on their time and you're
getting to know this new human being and
they're getting to know you every day
because every day you're knowing
something new about yourself you're
knowing something new about them and
that's the dynamic and that can be a
challenge and
um it's definitely taught me to Pace
myself
to and to have patience with myself and
to have patience with my kids their kids
they're just getting here they don't
know the way the world works and
a part of my job as their parent is to
help them
um and and that I'm silly
and it's okay to be silly and it's good
to be silly and it's healthy to be silly
and they bring that out of me and I love
that and I'm grateful to them for that
I'm grateful to them for so many things
but that silly aspect is important
um you know you got into your career at
a young age have your son shown any
interest in pursuing music and would you
support them getting into it as soon as
you did Titan was at the doctor's office
the other day and there's this um little
inside part kind of thing that they have
and inside it was he was underneath this
little thing and I just hear this little
angelical choir-like voice I said
because there was other kids over there
I said is that Titan it was such a shock
because he was just singing so it was so
beautiful and so Crystal Clear I was
like his voice is really beautiful and
it's not just because he's my kid like I
just it's it's really sound beautiful
and I said Son what are you singing and
he told me the song he was singing and
if he wanted to sing it's just like
great if he doesn't great like I'm not
tripping either way but I would
definitely support him but he's just
enjoying being a kid and being you know
getting into everything and being dirty
and coming home from school and you know
playing and learning and being a big
brother he's awesome
um I do have to ask next year is the
20th anniversary of Destiny fulfilled
when you think about that time in your
life and that album
what what words sort of come to mind to
you
I'd say
learning about myself
gut instincts
um reality
um fun that album was so much fun summer
um sunshine
silliness
grown it's so many things that come to
mind I that was such a fun album to put
together and very personal that was a
very personal album too I love that you
guys continue to support each other I
feel like that's so rare after bands
part ways do you plan on going to
Renaissance are you excited of course
I'm going to Renaissance I can't allow
the rest of the world to go to
Renaissance and I'm not going
it's my sister yeah
um I also love that you're a children's
book author now
um where do you get that inspiration
from like where do your ideas come from
well honestly the inspiration came from
my co-writer Jessica McKay she's a
writer as well as a teacher as well as a
wife and mother of three and she's so
brilliant and it was really cool to sit
down with her and she told me she had
all these ideas for children's books and
she told me about this book and it
literally sent me to tears because I was
dealing with Mom guilt at the time so we
took our time and uh we wrote it and
just made everything so intentional and
we actually learned that from another
author uh Rhoda
so Rhoda uh taught us so much about
um just what it's like to write a book
to write a children's book and she'd
written a couple herself and a couple of
New York Times bestsellers herself for
children's books and just really
to to have fun during the process as
well but I couldn't have done it without
those two women Jessica McKay and uh
Rhoda for sure you know you're uh like I
said you're an author you're a singer
your producer you're an actress I'm
curious out of those things what right
now is inspiring you the most
career-wise
to be honest uh film film and music are
really inspiring me
um a lot like it it stays in my psyche
um most of the time different ideas
things I want to do things I want to see
on screen stories I'd like to tell
um stories I've I've heard from other
people that I like to collaborate with
them on
um but yeah and music
making the soundtracks to all these
moments is really exciting to me and um
yeah filming filming TV and music of
course of course
um you know I know you're starting and
co-producing new Tyler Perry movie if
I'm correct in that like what can you
say what can you tease anything you can
no my smile says it all my smile says it
all
um
it's definitely a side of me I'll say no
one has seen before and I'm really
grateful to
Mr Perry for that he is so brilliant and
was so collaborative
you know and we all know he can do it
all himself he is so incredibly talented
and when I had different ideas he was
like okay
but very supportive and um he is one of
my favorite people he's become one of my
favorite people and we had a blast on
set a blast on set and I learned so much
so much now music for you anything you
can tease coming up for new music no I'm
not saying you know I feel like I've
gotten my own self and trouble I always
get so upset when somebody's like you
said you were gonna come out with and I
was like I just won't say anything in
the first place let me just be
spontaneous and just go in the studio
nobody knows and just randomly release
music that's the way it should be it
should be a surprise I feel like we
don't get surprises anymore you know
where's the mystery I love like a
surprise drop yes always and I feel like
the fans love it too absolutely okay so
we'll wait but is there like a genre
maybe that you haven't explored or would
like to explore or maybe somebody who
you really like their sound right now
and you'd like to collaborate with oh
it's a couple of artists who sound I'm
loving right now from
Victoria Monet to Lucky Day to her
um oh my gosh summer Walker I love her
new record pull up blah blah blah Jimmy
um there's another artist ebony who's
got a new EP out that's jamming it's so
many artists that are doing such
wonderful things and I just literally
heard the journey to I'm sorry the the
chorus to her's new song journey and it
literally had me in my feelings uh so I
feel like there's so many artists coming
with some really beautiful music and
it's intentional and it's authentic to
who they are
um but yeah it's it's very exciting